multiplique 3 x 2 x 5 x 7 y aquí lo que
tenemos son dos binomios los binomios
tienen dos términos que se están sumando
y te voy a enseñar a desarrollar esta
multiplicación de dos formas distintas
una muy mecánica a mí la verdad no me
gusta hacer las cosas mecánicamente
porque cuál es el problema de hacerlo de
esta forma que cuando tengas 35 años se
te va a olvidar la palabra mágica que
hacía que las cosas funcionaran y
entonces no vas a poder hacer la
multiplicación de estos dos binomios sin
embargo si entiendes por qué la
multiplicación de dos binomios es lo que
es ahí si te vas a acordar hasta que
tengas 100 años pero vamos a empezar por
la forma mecánica y después vamos a ver
por qué funciona la forma mecánica
porque tal vez te puedes encontrar con
esta mnemotecnia en el salón de clases
entonces es importante conocer lo que
hay la mnemotecnia en la palabra mágica
es
es un chistoso propósito para que te
acuerdes que son dos así no nada más una
entonces tenemos aquí a nada
a un gay son dos us muy importante eso
de que sean dos es la p es de los
primeros términos alguna de las hadas la
que tú quieras es la de los términos de
afuera a fuera la otra a es la de los
términos de adentro adentro y la uv es
la de los últimos términos últimos
últimos los primeros términos son el
primer término de cada paréntesis ok y
entonces usando a está dado
tenemos que tomar los primeros términos
de cada paréntesis y entonces tenemos al
primer término de este paréntesis por el
primer término de este paréntesis y
entonces nos queda 3
por 5 x después la queremos sumar los
términos de afuera y pues los términos
de afuera son estos dos términos con
todo y su símbolo de menos aunque
entonces tenemos por aquí 3x x menos 7 y
ahora nos toca los términos de adentro y
los términos de adentro son estos dos o
sea que nos queda 2 x 5x y finalmente
nos faltan los últimos términos ok este
es el último término de este paréntesis
y este es el último término de este otro
paréntesis entonces nos quedan dos por
menos 7 y listo
este es el desarrollo de esta
multiplicación de estos dos minutos y en
el fondo lo que hace es verificar que
multiplique cada uno de estos términos
por todos los términos del otro
paréntesis aunque tenemos aquí ya 3x por
5x aquí está y tenemos aquí a 3x por
menos 7 está aquí y lo mismo para el 2
tenemos a 2 x 5 x y 2 x menos 7 que está
por aquí y eso se debe a la propiedad
distributiva seguramente te acuerdas de
ella lo que nos dice la propiedad
distributiva es que si tenemos aquí a
por b nace esto de aquí es igual a por b
a por b más a por se aporte pero bueno
antes de ver este otro método que usa la
propiedad distributiva para ver cuánto
vale esta multiplicación de dos binomios
pues vamos a terminar con este método no
está
y ya es el desarrollo de esta
multiplicación pero todavía se puede
simplificar porque aquí tenemos 3x por 5
erc icv y esto es igual a 3 por 5 15 y
aquí tenemos x elevado a la potencia 1 y
otra x elevada a la potencia 1
entonces si multiplicamos estas dos
cantidades nos queda x elevado a la 1
más 1 o sea elevado al cuadrado por aquí
lo que tenemos es 3 de gist por menos 7
entonces 3 por menos 73 menos 21
entonces nos queda menos 20 1 y nos
falta multiplicar por la equis así es
que aquí va una equis ahora de aquí dos
por cinco diez y tenemos una equis y
finalmente dos por menos siete es menos
14 ahora aquí hay otros dos términos que
se pueden simplificar un poco más que
tenemos aquí una sola equis y aquí
también tenemos una sola equis entonces
podemos agrupar estos dos términos y
hacer algo así como la propiedad
distributiva inversa porque aquí tenemos
una equis que está multiplicando a menos
21 y a 10 también entonces eso es igual
a equis por menos 21 más 10 y menos 21
10 es menos 11 entonces de estos dos
términos tenemos menos 11 por equis este
término lo bajamos aquí menos 14 y este
término también lo bajamos nos queda 15
x cuadrada ok este es el resultado de
hacer esta multiplicación de binomios y
recuerda está mnemotecnia lo único que
hace es hacer que multiplique
cada uno de los términos de éste
6 con cada uno de los términos del otro
paréntesis ok
muy bien y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
el segundo método que lo que hace es
utilizar la propiedad distributiva dos
veces porque tenemos por aquí 3 x más 2
x 5 x 7 entonces vamos a aplicar la
propiedad distributiva en dos veces
tenemos por aquí a 5 x menos 7 x 3 x + 2
aunque entonces pensamos en este
paréntesis como una sola cosa ahora
recuerda que podemos cambiar estos dos
del lugar porque se están multiplicando
y entonces vamos a multiplicar todo este
paréntesis por 3x como si este
paréntesis fuera la a en la fórmula de
la propiedad distributiva y a eso le
vamos a sumar todo este paréntesis por 2
ok entonces haciendo la propiedad
distributiva nos queda 3 x
x por nuestro paréntesis que es 5x menos
7 más 2 por nuestro paréntesis 2 por 5 x
menos 7 y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
volver a aplicar la propiedad
distributiva pero con cada uno de estos
paréntesis entonces nos va a quedar 3 x
x 5 x y luego 3x x menos 7 y en este
paréntesis nos va a quedar 2 x 5 x + 2 x
menos 7 y escogí el color de estas
flechas completamente a propósito aquí 3
x x 5 x es exactamente este término aquí
3 x x menos 7 también es exactamente
este término y de este lado 2 x 5 x lo
tenemos por acá y 2 x menos 7 también lo
tenemos por acá así es que ya sabes
tienes que aplicar la propiedad
dos veces y entonces en lugar de
aprender tiene una palabra como tal
puede simplemente recordar la propiedad
distributiva y listo